so Israel hasn't responded with 1% of
the barbarism that was shown on Israeli
territory last Saturday not a bit of it
what Israel does have to do is to
reassert its own um
impenetrability its own um
impermeability and that is what one of
the many things that suffered such a
blow at the weekend the the uh belief
that Israeli intelligence is all knowing
took a huge hit the idea that the IDF is
endlessly able to defend the Israeli
people against all enemies took a
massive hit the idea that Tech uh can
can stand in for human beings that
border crossings and so on took a huge
hit the technological prowess and much
more has taken a huge hit so the most
important thing I should think that
Israel would need to do is to is to
build those uh things even if they are
myths back up